mimic law and reign McKenna who will
hear from later in the day have prepared
this sort of short course on answering
linear queries there's a nice connection
of course to Rachel and sessions
combined talk yesterday on synthetic
data but that won't miss a the explicit
first perspective taken here and thank
you thanks Adam right there a lot of
alexander's and Alexandra's in Eastern
Europe it's just not avoidable all right
so some disclaimers like Adam said this
is going to be this is like a little
short quick course on answering
accounting queries when I say linear
queries maybe I should have put counting
course I'll be talking about counting
things with differential privacy and
this is sort of a little course we put
together with general me Ryan and I'll
cover sort of a more theoretical like a
theoretical computer scientists
perspective and then I think Jerome II
Ryan would take it more to the empirical
and applied side and and I think we'll
talk a little bit about sense this is
like a one use case maybe so
another disclaimer or like an actual
disclaimer this is probably one of the
most studied topics in differential
privacy so there's like a ton of work
there any attempt to give a story would
like be somewhat biased and miss some
things out so this sort of my bias taken
like some of the theory behind counting
things with differential privacy so I'll
start with basics and we'll take it from
there
stop me at any time I'm assuming that
you know the definition of differential
privacy and maybe you have seen the
Gaussian mechanism before although I'll
explain it and I will try not to assume
much more
but there will be linear algebra for
example so there there will be some
mathematics so let me start let me start
with some basics so this is sort of just
setting up this the setting like how we
usually think of these things is we have
a database which is some table where
every row in the table corresponds to
the data of one person and usually is
probably convenient to think of really
you know a table where you have rows
which correspond to people and call them
the correspond to attributes although
the exact format of what a row is for us
will not be that important
so when you have a database we sort of
need to know what a valid database role
is maybe hoping I'm using this correctly
like a more database language we need to
know the schema right so we'll use this
notion of a data universe to define what
it means for something to be a valid
database role so the universe which I'm
denoting by this Germanic looking you is
there's just a set of all possible valid
data base rows so usually you can think
of this is something as simple as if you
have a database with these attributes
you have some idea of what is a valid
attribute value and the data universe
could be something like just all
possible you know sequences of value
attribute value so all possible
combinations of like a possible ID a
possible value for gender a possible
value for like level of education and a
possible let's say value for age in ears
okay so that's the data universe and
then we think of a database it's just a
collection of rows from this data
universe so I'll use X superscript I for
the role of the database so every
database row must be you know a valid
database row that is an element of this
universe and again each row corresponds
to date of one person and here is the
main thing we'll talk about today which
will be counting query so will be what
talking about counting the number of
roles in a database that satisfy some
property here is how here's just some
notation to talk about this will be
interested in a predicate what I call a
practical which is just a function that
assigns to every possible database row
every element in the universe a value 0
or 1 so think of one so think of this
function taking value 1 if the database
role satisfies the property you have in
mind and the function taking value 0 if
the database rule does not satisfy the
property have in mind for example one
property could be is this a row that
corresponds to a male person and that's
just the function which you know takes
the database row looks at the gender
column like the gender attribute and
checks is like do I see em there if I
see em there then the function returns 1
this could be more general you could
assign not just you know yes or no to
database roles you could assign some
numbers so you could do some sort of
weighted counting but I'll focus mostly
on this you know pure predicate case and
then such a pretty good so this is again
just the property that the database row
could satisfy or not this induces a
counting query okay so the counting
query just counts how many rows in the
database satisfy this predicate and the
way you can encode this in mathematics
very simply is just to sum over the rows
in the database the value that the
predicate takes on this row right
because here for everything in the sum I
get a 1 if the database no satisfies the
predicate and I get a 0 otherwise ok so
if I add all these virus you just get
the number of rows that satisfy the
pretty good
and I'll overload notation a little bit
I'm using Q for the predicate I'll also
use it so when I apply Q to a single
database row that's the predicate that
tells me is the database row like does
it satisfy the predicate or not when I
apply it to a database I just mean the
count of the number of rows that satisfy
it is pretty good sometimes in
literature you can see the normalized
version where you divide by the total
number of rows in the database so this
gives you the fraction of rows that
satisfy the predicate rather than the
count they're basically equivalent
except when you read a paper you sort of
have to pay attention are you
normalizing
could be a little confusing but not too
much of course we almost never care
about a single counting query so just
counting one thing is usually like is
not enough information usually we care
about something more like collars have
washed out quite a bit it's okay
we care more about something like this
which is a collection of counting
queries that can give us what more
information what our data looks like so
this is just an example I took from the
census website so I'm what we usually
going to be interested in is a
collection of K counting queries and
again I would you just look a little bit
of overloading of notation so this Q is
the collection of counting quiz which I
call a workload this may be a term more
common in like work in the database
community but I like it so I'll use it
so Q will be this collection of counting
queries which are which we want to
answer and I'll use this notation Q of a
database to give me just you know the
list of answers to all the queries in
the workload so this is just the vector
of answers to all the queries in the
workload okay and there is a so those
are kind of all counting queries there's
a 1 that's what got one out do you see
that one is a little strange compare it
to the others your own pointing this out
to me I decided to leave it there's the
sacred sex ratio which you can see I
think is a normalized query because it's
like number of number of males like the
proportion of males or you can say
there's a fraction like a ratio of two
counting queries and then I guess the
point is you can combine counting query
answers to get more than counting
queries yes question
I'm not sure what you mean do you mean
that like if i satisfy predicate a and
all satisfied it could be no no so
actually that's quite important I think
that could be overlap and this is a very
good question
here you see possibly if you're male
you're not female in this database but
overall so for example if you contribute
to 18 years and over you may contribute
to 65 years and over so these things
could overlap and this will be like this
is important so they kind of like the
queries in a word cloud could all be
correlating sort of arbitrary ways and
this is part of the challenge good so
now let me start to introduce some with
the formalism that's very convenient to
talk about counting queries this is
something that I think Rachel mentioned
briefly yesterday when she talked about
the multiplicative wise mechanism which
is this notion of a histogram which is
sort of a very convenient way to think
about a database especially for the
kinds of algorithm that we'll talk about
ok so what is a histogram this is a way
to represent a database as a vector this
vector has one entry for each possible
row in the universe so it's a very high
dimensional vector potentially right it
has one coordinate for each possible
database role like not each database row
but each possible database turn alright
so for all animals in the universe and
for any possible row x the value of this
vector at X is the number of rows in the
database that are equal to X ok
all right so H H sub X is just the
number of copies of X in the database so
just to give one example let's say the
universe is we have a database with
three binary attributes so this is
universe and this is one possible
database and for example here this row 0
0 1 appears twice in the corresponding
entry in the histogram I have the number
2 the Rho 0 0 0 does not appear at all I
have a 0
a question what histogram is some of
those relations about a histogram and
also a definition if you haven't seen
this before
l1 norm of a vector is the sum of the
absolute values of the coordinates in
this case the apps' values don't play a
role so if I look at the l1 norm of the
histogram this is just so because
everything is positive I can skip the
absolute values here and then just do
then this is just the sum of the entries
in the histogram and remember each entry
tells me how many times do I see this
row type in the database so if I add all
these counts up I just get the total
number of rows in the database okay so
the this l1 norm of the histogram which
is the sum of the entries is just equal
to n which is the number of rows and the
other simple innovation is that if two
databases X and X prime or neighbouring
that is I can get one from the other by
adding or removing a row if I subtract
the histogram this is going to look like
something like like this it's so this H
minus H prime for two every databases
will look like some vector like this a
bunch of zeros a plus or minus one and a
bunch of zeros right I've got a plus a
plus or minus one exactly what I added
or removed at all to go from egg from X
to X Prime and you can see that if I now
add up the absolute values of the
entries in this difference between the
histograms I just get one okay so this
is what I'm saying here that one norm of
the difference between two neighboring
histograms is one so basically the
things we care about like some things
that we care about with a database like
the size and being neighboring or
reflected in the histogram so the other
important abstraction for us is what's
called the query matrix and the point
here is that you can very conveniently
encode a workload of queries a bunch of
counting queries by a matrix okay so
each row in the matrix is just the truth
table of this counting query in other
words this is a matrix which is indexed
so the rows enters by the queries and
the columns indexed by the universe
elements
and the entry corresponding to query Q
and University month like possible
database row X is just equal to the
value of Q on X that is does exciti spy
the predicate Q or not okay if you think
about it if I allow arbitrary queries
arbitrary accounting queries how would
you even give me those queries if I want
to answer them how would you specify
them in the most generic way to specify
them it just to tell me for each query
and each possible database role does the
predicate evaluate to 1 or 0 right and
this is just what this what this matrix
is each row is just this like truth
table of the query so here is one
example and what one interesting class
of queries let's say we have the same
three attribute binary databases and
then let's look at the queries which are
known is the one-way marginals okay this
is so in this case there are three of
those queries if here I have like D
attributes do BD of them and each query
so the I've query basically asks is the
ith bit of X 1 or 0 okay so you see for
example Q 1 asks is the if the first bit
of the database row is 1 or 0 and if we
list all possible database roles here
for the first four of course to get a 0
because the first like the way it listed
them the first bit is 0 for those 4 for
the next for the first bit is 1 and I
get a 1 here and so I just have the 3
truth tables just so now the point to
this is that why did my first like what
is my title slides say counting queries
sorry
linear queries not counting queries
because counting queries are linear with
respect to the histogram they're just
linear functions of the histogram
okay and this is easy to see so again
what was the counting query I could
write it as you know sum over the South
Rosen database of the value of the
predicate on that row that is just the
count of roles that satisfy this
predicate but I could also write this as
sum over all the possible all the
possible database roles all X in the
universe of Q of X so does this possible
database table satisfy the predicate or
not times the number of times that this
row appears in the actual database and
if you remember what matrix vector
multiplication is you see that this is
just like this thing is just the
coordinate corresponding to query Q of
this matrix vector product WH okay so
this may be easier to verify with a
piece of paper so if you don't see it
immediately you can trust me
are there questions the point is I can
encode my counting queries which is this
matrix vector product if I take the
query matrix and the histogram is my
vector this is most of the formula the
one last piece is that we have to have a
way to measure error okay so we know at
least since the work of copy with your
dinner that if if you don't add any
error to a bunch of counting queries a
bunch of weight possible overlapping
counting calories you could reconstruct
the database so in general we will need
to deal with error then we will need
some way to measure error so here are
two ways to measure area I almost talked
about this first one which is probably
the most natural one which is what I
call word or word is usually called
worst case error okay so I'll use this
notation you see what the infinity sign
is there but this is just the notation
for the worst case error of a mechanism
on queries q and databases of size n so
first this is a worst case notion over
all databases so we were we're asking
what is the worst possible earth is my
mom that my mechanism makes over all
databases and then I also take the
expected worst error over all possible
queries so I'm assuming that the
mechanism takes
the queries queue and a database X and
I'm you're just using this notation for
like the answer that the mechanism gives
to query queue okay so this is just the
error this is just how different is the
mechanisms answer from the actual query
answer in absolute value right and then
the expected maximum of those errors
overall queries in my workload okay so
you can imagine other notions where ask
that both these Maxima like that this
maximum error is less than something
with probability at least like 99% I'm
choosing to do expectation here because
I think it's mathematically a little
simpler and from here you can easily get
high probability guarantees as well and
you can also write this within this like
linear algebraic notation that we just
introduced so stead of taking maximum
overall databases of size n you can
equivalent to take a maximum over all
histograms where the entries some 20 or
at most n guess you should have set
equal to n here sorry and then this you
see that this maximum error is just the
L infinity norm the maximum absolute
value of the difference between those
two vectors so just the LD into norm of
the true query answers minus the vector
of clear answer is given my by my
mechanism hey but sometimes it's also
natural convenient or makes sense to
look at like a more average notion of
error which is mean squared error so
here I'm still taking worst case overall
databases but instead of taking the
maximum error over all queries I'm
averaging the squared errors and taking
this expected average squared error so
this is the mean squared error
you notice that okay after you take this
like expectation I do hit it with a
square root and I'm just doing this so
that those two men like notions are very
comparable like I just want them to be
on on the same scale because otherwise
would be very hard to compare them okay
I think it just the thing that make
sense basically like right and again you
can write this sort of in a morally now
jabrai way I won't dwell on this too
much sure
okay so we're mostly deal with this
questions
yes so I can't imagine you'd be able to
get get there but to what extent can we
kind of talked about like error
distributions for the mechanisms the
types of mechanisms that you mean how
the sort of detail like not just the
expected maximum error but how it's like
how like we were to be close to this
like expected maximum error yeah I was
thinking about this but I don't have a
very good answer I think for for
mechanism that we use usually we add
some noise this with pretty well
concentrated we sometimes do things on
top of that but usually that still
pretty like this concentration is still
preserved but it'll be interesting to
note generically can we sort of always
make sure that if you have this
guarantee on error then you can also
guarantee like a high probability to
think automatically I'm feel like I
haven't thought about this you know you
yeah as I was preparing the slices I
realized that this should be understood
better maybe okay but just
okay III didn't say what expectations
are sorry I should have clicked forward
sooner so all expectations over the
randomness of the mechanism there's
nothing else random on this slide at
this point except the mechanism you
notice that this notion of error is
worst case over all possible databases
of size and of course in a most
statistical application like what I
talked about yesterday
or all the talks yesterday it could be
important to actually not have this
worst-case notion of error but assume
that the database comes from some ID
distribution and then you can sometimes
get better results this is sort of
hinted by Galton yesterday I think a
little bit yeah there's there's some
problems for which we know that assuming
iid I think beat some lower bounds that
you otherwise get without assuming iid
good this is almost the end of my sort
of basics part like the basics part of
my talk now let me sort of give a
glimpse of what I'll talk about
basically so here is the the type of
mechanisms like very roughly and broadly
maybe work somewhat incomplete the type
of mechanisms for answering answering
counting queries first we have the
really simple mechanisms which are I'm
basically calling them data and workload
independent although maybe this is a
little bit false but these are
mechanisms that just take the true query
answers and add some noise and the noise
is like very weakly correlated with what
the queries you asking or accept maybe
knowing how many of them they are or a
little more precisely
except for knowing what is the
sensitivity of the queries okay so those
are simple mechanisms like gaussian
laplace noise mechanisms where once you
know the sensitivity of your queries you
know how much noise to add and that's
all you use about your queries another
class or mechanisms that are sort of
data independent like they basically add
noise from the same distribution no
matter what the database is is what I
mean by data independent but the kind of
noise you add is adapted to the workload
and often this this adaptiveness so like
this maybe adapter is now
anyway so dislike fitting of the noise
to the workload could improve the kind
of results you get and finally we have
mechanisms that do different things
depending on what data they see and this
there definitely I should say like those
are just examples they're not like
exhaustive list at all those are
mechanisms they try to learn the
database as they answer queries and
they're more like the private about
liquidy voice that right you talked
about yesterday you said the first one
could depend on say the number clearly
is that like what is the workload
essentially so the workload is always
just a bunch of counting queries for me
okay the specific query that yeah yeah
so you know like it's not a very clean
distinction because you sort of always
need to know something about the
workload but I'm saying here like just
think of Gaussian Laplace noise
mechanisms which only use sort of how
many queries you have and what is the
sensitivity for example we'll see those
essentially don't really distinguish
between am I asking K independent
queries or am I asking the same query K
types
and here's the point I'll make later I
think I'll skip it for now yes so right
that's a good question again everything
so at the end I have a slide with things
I'm not talking about
so everything I'll I decided to focus on
mechanisms where you know the whole
workload ahead of time they are like
they are mechanisms like private
multiplicative weights could handle the
case where you get queries one by one
and you have an adaptive analyst we know
less there and I will not talk about it
so much but it's an interesting
direction maybe four maybe topic for
more discussions here all right so let
me start with the really basic
mechanisms in particular the Gaussian
noise mechanism so this is something
that we saw already on the first day
kunal gave us basically a complete proof
of its privacy so let me remind you so
what is the Gaussian noise mechanism to
make that Gaussian noise how much
Gaussian noise do you add to each query
answer well it's enough to add an amount
that's proportional to the sensitivity
of your queries of your query workload
so here is one way to measure the
sensitivity of the query workload this
is maximum over all neighboring
databases X and X prime of some norm of
the difference between the query answers
right so I take the vector of query
answers on X the vector of clear answers
on X prime I subtract one from the other
this is the difference in query answers
and then I take the the Euclidean norm
of this difference okay so your normal
you don't remember I squared the entries
add them up and take a square root
sorry from saying things that are too
basic but ask me questions if you don't
understand what I'm saying okay so let's
write this equivalently with our like
linear algebraic notation because this
ends up being convenient so you see how
I use this notation for Delta
sensitivity of the queries but because
they can encode the queries is the
workload is like sorry as this query
matrix also so I also like overload this
notation - I love overall you mutation
and now you also use Delta to of the
workload of like the query matrix so
what am I saying I'm just - taking the
maximum out - norm of the difference
between the query answers on database X
and the query actually on database X
prime ok but we saw that those query
answers are just W times H and those are
just W times H prime and we also saw
that two neighboring databases have
histograms that whose difference look
something like this right so whose
difference has l1 norm at multiple okay
so I see this like maximum of this
difference I can just pull like because
everything is linear I can just put W
out and I'm just left with H - H prime
which is just some vector of a1 norm one
okay so I see that this will extensity
VT just ends up being this maximum of
the l2 norm of the Euclidean norm of W
times V over all the vectors V that
basically looks like this so if you
think about this what this mean is a
little bit you see that if you take any
query matrix this sensitivity just ends
up being the largest norm of any column
and you see that this expression so
basically I can put plus or minus 1 and
whether it is plus or minus 1 doesn't
matter for the norm I can put a plus or
minus 1 in any coordinate that
corresponds to any one of these columns
and it can always pick out the one which
has the largest norm and this is the
biggest that this can get for example
for this query matrix for the one-way
margin also like three attribute
databases you see this one column which
has all ones
clearly this has the biggest norm and
this has norm square root of three okay
so in in general this like L -
sensitivity is always bounded by square
root of the number of queries I have
this is like the way to see the
sensitivity for linear queries like for
more complicated queries computing the
sensitivity could be complicated for
linear is as long as you write them as
this matrix you just look at the largest
call okay
and now the Gaussian noise mechanism
these I think these are the citations
that seen here a while ago Alden you're
correct I hope they're still correct so
you see this is a mechanism that's in a
way older than I mean it is older than
differential privacy and it just says
take the true query answers at
independent Gaussian noise to every
query answer and the Gaussian okay so
the Gaussian noise you add has mean 0
and it's variance is proportional to
this factor Sigma which looks like this
that factor only depends on the epsilon
and Delta privacy parameters and the
sensitivity of the query workload
squared okay so you basically add noise
according to the sensitivity with a
factor that depends on the privacy
parameters
so this achieve is absolutely out the
differential privacy so how well does
this do so let's take let's say any
workload of K queries if we look at the
air at the worst case error of this
mechanism on this workload and a
database of any size is what you see the
mechanism doesn't care what's the size
of the database so this end here
actually doesn't play a role you can see
that so the the noise I'm adding to each
query is sort of if I ignore the
dependence on privacy parameters is
proportional to the sensitivity I should
say for the rest of the talk I'll assume
epsilon Delta and call are constant and
I'll ignore them I'm not saying you
should ignore them in general just makes
the math a little cleaner just I want to
have less scary expressions all right so
this is the amount of noise I'm roughly
adding to each query answer and there's
K of them and you have to sort of see so
you know the biggest noise could be
bigger like square root of log number of
queries times bigger than its variance
so you get this sort of bound and you
can see in the worst case if you have at
least one column in your query matrix
which has all ones this will be
square root of K and this way usually
happens or not always so in the worst
case you get something like this arrow
which is proportional to X square root
of the number of queries times the log
factor okay so this is optimum for
one-way marginal some D dimensional data
this is a nice result by mark bun John
Holman and Sun overdone so he sort of
have identified the optimal mechanism in
differential privacy and we can stop of
course not
this is silly because they're definitely
better things you can do for query
workloads that are not one-way marginals
okay for one-way marginals we've
identified the optimal thing i guess but
what if you have the same query repeated
k times this mechanism wouldn't know
this is true right it just knows the
sensitivity the sensitivity is the
biggest it can be its square root of k
so it would add this much noise
essentially and but you could clearly
just answer the query once and then copy
the answer over K times this gives you
constant error as a possible route of
care and a more interesting example or
threshold queries sometimes I think all
range queries also so in the simplest
case threshold queries you assume that
each one of your database entries like
each one of your database rows it's just
a number so every person just has a
number and the queries ask how many
people in the database have a number
which is less than some threshold T so
if I write the workload matrix it looks
something like this okay for order the
university much like one to capital n I
get like an N by n began by began query
matrix which just looks like this lower
triangular matrix okay I think I did
this correctly okay and okay it's not
immediately obvious but I'll talk more
about this in a minute
here you can achieve square root of law
I'm sorry like some power of log n kind
of error whereas here you'd get square
root of n kind of error right so this
mechanism is clearly not the best you
can do all the time it's sometimes the
best thing you can do which is
so how can you beat the Gaussian
mechanism on threshold queries for just
repeating the same query K times it's
clear you just answer the query once but
what can you do professional queries and
here is the he's like one there are a
few different approaches this is not the
best one
maybe Jerome talks a bit more about this
I'm not sure but here's maybe the
simplest sort of using I teach data
structures every other semester well
this always reminds me of like
undergraduate data structures ok vo
trees not really ok so how can you
answer actual queries like kind of
logarithmic kind of error so I think
many of you have seen this but for those
of you who haven't all right those of
you who really like this maybe it's a
nice refresher so the idea is to answer
a different set of queries which we'll
be calling the strategy queries and what
are these different set of queries I've
arranged them in a tree so let's assume
I'm answering threshold queries on the
universe so every database row is a
number between 1 and 8 and my strategy
queries are first I believes I'm asking
how many elements of the database are 1
how many years - how many are 3 and so
on then the second level of asking how
many database in the how many elements
in the database are 1 or 2 this is one
query or three or four or five or six
and here I'm asking how many are between
one and four how many are between five
and eight and so on and finally this is
a guy's not really necessary this you
just end this is just the total number
of elements in the database all right so
I'm asking the strategy queries and now
the point is think about the sensitivity
if I add or remove a single row to the
database this can only affect the nodes
on the path to the root from the so if I
add remove a seven to the database I can
only affect this query this one this one
in this one and you see the way this is
supposed to be a complete binary tree
you see in general this would be like
about log and many different queries
that are affected so they are to
sensitivity you can see it's
proportional to square root of log of
the universe size okay so that's good
the sensitivity is much better now
not trivial it's not square root of a
number of queries anymore but I've
answered a different set of queries so
that now the point is that I can
reconstruct my original queries as a
linear combination of the queries that
I've actually answered so I'm going to
answer those queries with the Gaussian
noise mechanism and then I can
reconstruct say this threshold query
which asks how many elements in the
database are between one and seven I can
answer this by just adding up those
query answers and you see you now you
always need to add at most one sort of
query per level of the tree so that you
always add no more than like log n of
them all right so this yes so this is
like effectively as it's like you're
representing the mattress in a different
basis like sparse basis and then kind of
taking the for every query take a linear
span number of columns here yeah and now
I'll say something very similar yes oh
you'll be annoyed good so let me give
you like a maybe this I think is
familiar to many people and also it's
quite intuitive let me give you sort of
a different way to think about it which
is as factoring which is similar to what
Roy was just saying I want to think of
this is factoring the query matrix as
the product of two matrices so what am I
saying
I'll write the query matrix as R times a
so what is a a it's just the query
matrix for the strategy queries all
right so in this case a will be the
query matrix I attempted to write down
what it looks like but I think it's not
very illuminating a just the query
matrix that encodes these queries in
this case ok these are again some
counting queries so I can again encode
them as a query matrix okay then I also
need a way to take the answers to the
strategy queries and reconstruct answers
to my actual queries and this is what
the matrix R tells me ok so the so
called the reconstruction matrix and
this I'll call the strategy matrix all
right the matrix of strategy queries
good so then what is the mechanism let's
say I found some nice way to factor my
matrix so in the case of this lower
triangular matrix I can use this stuff
and it can extract kind of two matrices
out of it so what they do I answer the
strategy queries with the Gaussian noise
mechanism and this is just the plain
vanilla Gaussian noise mechanism where
ad no it's proportional to the
sensitivity now the sensitivity of a so
like one place where you could be
winning is that the sensitivity of a is
much smaller than the sensitivity of the
of the original workload like here okay
and then I get noisy answers to my
strategy queries I need to reconstruct
answers to my actual queries so I just
multiply everything by my reconstruction
matrix R ok so what does the what is the
error that this matrix has so let's like
look at just kind of the vector of
errors that I matter like the noise
vector that I'm adding essentially so
let me just take what the mechanism is
computing which is this and subtract the
true query answers from that and I see
that okay
r times a times H is just W times H
which is the true query answers so I'm
just left with like R times G so this is
the basically the noise vector I'm
adding okay and with like a little bit
of math you can convince yourself that
each entry of our times G is a Gaussian
again so it's a linear combination of
Gaussian so it's again a Gaussian which
has variance which is again the Sigma
factor which is always-there times Delta
sin city sorry the right times Delta
sensitivity of the strategies times the
corresponding row of the role of R so
times the norm of the row that tells us
how to reconstruct the ice query from
the strategy queries okay so you can see
in this case this like norm of this row
just ends up being kind of proportional
to how many of these strategy queries
and to the square root of how many of
the strategy queries I need to add up
and for threshold queries we can what
I've argued basically is that both the
sensitivity of the strategy queries and
this these guys are bounded by a log of
the universe size so I'm essentially
adding about a log and noise per query
so let's look at this a little more
generally don't take R to be so I want
once I think the queries I also fix or
are you saying is it is it unique good I
think you're saying kind of here I just
always add the same noise to every
strategy query so I think if I allowed
more general noise I think it wouldn't
be necessarily would I help you because
at the end so for a fixed way to do this
it could help I think but at the end I'm
going to like find the best way to write
W as R times a and then it may be
doesn't matter I think as mixes ok let's
look at this a little more generally
where the other questions I'm sorry this
maybe it was like a newborn slide I
think
okay so a little more generally again
this is the mechanism I'm writing wer
times a I answer the strategy queries I
reconstruct and again the error vector
is this and more generally what is the
distribution of the error vector it's a
Gaussian whose covariance matrix so this
is how the covariance matrix is okay
proportional to the this function of the
privacy parameters proportional to the
sensitivity of the strategy queries and
then proportional and and then like both
these numbers multiply these are our
transpose which you can convince
yourself is kind of so this is the row
that are placed in this covariance okay
so this is just a calculation I'm not
going to go through and now you can see
that the worst case error for any family
or like any workload of K queries on any
database size so again we're doing
something that doesn't depend read on
the database size this end plays no row
so the error is going to be bounded by
this kind of expression this is again
just using this fact the the fact that
the vector of errors is this Gaussian
and using standard facts about Gaussian
okay so what you end up getting after
like a little bit of calculation is that
the error of this mechanism is
proportional to the maximum norm of a
role of the reconstruction matrix R
which by the way is the same as kind of
the maximum square root of diagonal
entry of this covariance matrix but
think of it as like the maximum norm of
a row of R times the maximum norm of a
column of a which is the sensitivity we
said times a factor that depends on the
number of queries but the main thing is
this okay so when we factor this matrix
like this we have some contribution from
how we reconstruct and some contribution
from most strategy queries we ask we
want this product to be small okay and
the inside of the matrix mechanism which
was proposed I think in a slightly
different form for average case error by
Li dorama Clow I drew McGregor
and the chorus doggie was is just the
following simple idea once you write
once you realize that you can think of
these mechanisms like this mechanism for
threshold queries as we sort of like
factoring into reconstruction and
strategies adding noise to the
strategies and reconstructing and once
you realize this is the error that
you're getting how do you choose RNA of
course you just try to minimize this
right you just try to minimally you have
an error bound you have a class of
mechanisms and error but you try to
minimize the error bound okay so and
this is what you get so I'm just
introducing a little bit of notation so
I'll use this gamma of W the reason I'm
calling it gamma is because it's sort of
a standard it turns out function on
matrices but I'll use gamma W for sort
of the minimum of this like the
important part of this error bound like
the part of this error bound that I can
optimize I cannot do anything about the
locks the square root of log K so this
is basically up to the square root of
locate this is the minimum that I can
achieve with this method over all
possible ways to write WS reconstruction
times strategies and then the matrix
mechanism uses the optimal solution here
and that's what we had on the previous
slide and then of course the worst case
error that you're getting is this like
minimum gamma times square root of okay
yes Adam asked this question again
and so one question was whether or not
it's sort of without loss of generality
that you should that same noise to every
answer on a on the strategy query as
strategy queries and I guess you know
also does it matter if I you know the
difference between for that question may
be mean squared error and L infinity
error or different I don't know
and then this the related the second
question which sort of goes with that is
to what extent approximating W by a
product would somehow buy me something
that exact equality in both cases
there's sort of some question about how
much loss of generality there is in this
formula so the first question do I need
to add the same noise every query answer
so every slavery start to every strategy
query right so you can model this boy
instead of adding different amounts of
noise every scaling in some way yeah
like I think both of great questions I I
don't have immediate answers for the
first question I'm pretty sure that that
this does at least as well but I would
need to double check and the second
question can I just approximate W that's
a great question I I haven't thought
about it if I was talking about I think
there was a I think there was a
technique that tried to find a rule of
yeah we have a paper on this
do we we don't okay well thank you all
for did you want to say I think there's
a paper that tries to find like a
low-rank approximation okay solve an
easier optimization problem it's a very
natural proton yeah interesting
yeah so how the version I remember had
some approximation component but you
know maybe that was just me so you guys
also talked about sort of the pure
privacy version of this where the
occupation problem is harder and I guess
you need to do some approximate things
maybe there's a question like how you
can you solve this right which is what
I'll talk about okay good good questions
thanks I reduced to making the matrix a
I don't think so in general and this is
one thing that you can try so here in
this analysis we're doing something
simple we're just using kind of a chair
and often a union bound but you could do
something tighter and kind of but I
don't I I don't think you can just
assume this is yeah I don't think that's
true
we get that down to a law law so I
should I should say there is like some
work which it's not phrased is work on
differential privacy but I think can
apply with Kunal and a few other people
where we look at these sorts of
optimization problems and you can sort
of you can put another function here
rather than just like the maximum norm
overall a more complicated function
which kind of absorbs the square root of
log K and and kind of can account for
the cases where you you can do better
like you don't need the square root of
loci but the whole thing becomes a
little more complicated and I haven't
really tried it much in the context of
differential privacy so these problems
end up in other like show up in other
places too
but I'm not sure that you can just make
it the number of startup strategy
queries I think that's not true
necessarily queries there are cases when
the log is unavoidable that is Troy I
think not prefix is log n the best
results we know have an additional
square root
so for this mechanism yes but there are
other mechanisms that maybe can okay I'm
not even for this simpler and what a
special case be I don't believe we know
anything better
okay I think that may be true just so I
write it is interesting to see what to
do with this look I think I'll move on
with your no more questions okay that
this is a little maybe massy but I'll
introduce some concepts that we use
later so I think it's important I let's
go through it slowly so I want to give a
different interpretation of what we just
did okay so it was very natural let me
make it less natural maybe it's natural
in a different way so the main point
here is I want to introduce this object
3 me so let's remember again neighboring
databases you look at the histograms and
again we know that the difference
between histograms looks like something
like this
so if you look at the difference between
the query answers they can get on to
neighboring databases this is this sort
of difference I can of course because
this is just a matrix vector product
pull W out and I see this is some vector
which has this form so I can so I know
that this lies in the image of the l1
ball this is the image of all vectors of
l1 norm at most one under multiplication
by W and all this is saying is if you
think about about what this means
so I'm saying right what this really
means is just this difference between
the query answers on two neighbouring
databases must always lie in the convex
hull of plus minus the columns of the
matrix
so for example if I have this query
matrix if I look at the comments have
plus minus it's columns it's something
it looks something like this
parallelogram or parallelogram right I
did
basic math in Bulgaria I'm not I think
it's called a parallelogram okay
and this in in general this convex hull
of plus minus the columns of the matrix
is what we call the sensitivity polytope
so and this is why we call it a
sensitivity polytope so again we call
this entity pointer because it tells us
how query answer is vary from one
database donor from one database to a
neighboring database so if I take this
sensitivity polytope this convex hull of
plus/minus these columns if I Center it
so it's a century symmetric convex body
right so if I Center it at the true
query answers then for any neighboring
database the query answers would lie
inside this recenter sensitivity
polytope so it tells us exactly how the
query answers can vary when I move from
a vector of query answers to the query
answers on a neighboring database again
it's in a way it gives us much more
precise information about the
sensitivity than just this number which
we call the sensitivity because it tells
us really the geometry of how query
answers can vary from one database to a
neighboring database so for example the
usual sensitivity that I defined a bunch
of slides ago is just the radius of the
smallest bowl that contains this guy
okay but you see this point provides us
more detailed information for example if
I have the same query repeated K times
the sensitivity polytope will just look
like a line so it sort of tells us that
the queries are very correlated like if
if one query answer changes that all of
them change in that case or if they're
all like uncorrelated it would be like
much more kind of round kind of shape so
then you can so I won't go into details
here I'll just quickly say what you can
with the match mechanism
sort of fitting an ellipsoid given by
this reconstruction a strategy matrices
you can see it as fitting an ellipsoid
around the sensitivity polytope and
trying to make this ellipsoid as small
as possible in given directions I won't
dwell on this I think this is the main
point I want to take out do like take
from this slide I'll be doing on time
my timer here says like 50 52 minutes
whatever you've got about 10 minutes
left because he started a little bit
right so let me go back to kind of the
natural maybe way to think about the
mattress mechanism again okay so we
wanted to find us reconstruction and
strategy matrices which minimize this
product which gives us up to a log
factor a bound on on the air that we are
getting so we have to solve this
minimization problem and when you see
this minimization problem it's not
obviously like a convex minimization
problem if you can just throw into a
solver and solve when I first saw these
kind of problems it looks very strange
try this with your factoring some matrix
you're multiplying two functions why
would this be nice well it turns out you
can rewrite this in a nice way it's like
a important but simple observation you
can always multiply the reconstruction
matrix by some number T as long as you
divide the strategy matrix by the same
number they would still clearly multiply
to W right because the t + 1 / T would
cancel and you can also see so this was
the maximum norm of a row this was the
maximum norm of a column so if I do this
this would scale by T this was kept by 1
over T so this product also wouldn't
change okay so when I do this nothing
changes
about this problem so I can always
assume that by rescaling I can always
assume that those two terms are the same
in an optimal solution and they're both
equal to square root of the minimum so
with this observation I can write this
minimization problem is a semi definite
program
okay so I've written it not quite as a
semi definite program isn't work out
what's called a vector program so this
is an optimization problem where I'm
minimizing some T this is a number and
except T the other variables are I have
like a vector variable for every row of
our a column like another vector
variable for every column of a and it is
that an optimal solution T will be just
this gamma this minimum so I'm
minimizing T subject to this constraint
which just tells me that
our times they should be equal to W so
these are just some constraints on inner
products these tell me that the norm the
squared norm of every role of our should
be at most T and also the squared norm
of any column of a should be at most e
so you can convince yourself that this
exactly encodes this problem and this
can easily be turned into what's called
a semi definite program and they're like
highly optimized solvers that you can
use it's still a challenge if you have
like large like if your matrices are
large it's still a challenge semi
definite programming like in in theory
it's solvable in polynomial time in
practice it's not the most efficient
kind of program you can so but at least
there's a lot of work put into efficient
solvers that you can serve leverage okay
and I think okay go on for as long as I
can I guess so let's talk a little bit
about how good is the matrix mechanism
is this like the best is this now the
best mechanism a differential privacy
okay so let me introduce a little bit of
notation so I'll use this notation opt
so this is the optimal error if you can
achieve for like some fixed epsilon and
Delta the optimum will say like worst
case error that you can achieve on these
queries and on databases of size n over
all epsilon Delta differential private
mechanisms it's just notation for like
the best that you can do on the
differential privacy and what we can
show what we could show with kunal and
Li Jiang during a great internship in
Microsoft Research a number of years ago
was the following kind of result so if
you look at the optimal error that you
can achieve okay the maximum optimal
error that you can achieve overall
database sizes so this is a little
strange this is basically saying the
best error you can achieve that doesn't
depend on database size like the best
error that you can achieve for like very
large databases is another way to say it
then okay because the error that the
matrix mechanism achieves it doesn't
depend on the database size this
oh and the optimal error is clearly at
most the error that the matrix mechanism
can achieve because that's what won the
French back mechanism so I have this
bound and interestingly if you have
large enough databases you can also
prove a lower bound okay
so again this is just the matrix
mechanism we could show that if I allow
like large enough databases you can also
prove this like matching up to log
factors lower bound which is a
reconstruction attack so you can show
that mechanism that is that on all
databases have error much less than this
a lower reconstruction attack of the
style in Donora nism have some proof
sketch but it's not okay so like very
very sketchy so the point is that if
this minimum that you can achieve here
for error is large then this tells you
something about the matrix which allows
you to give a reconstruction attack I'll
just say that in the proof in order to
make the reconstruction attack work we
need databases of size about number of
queries over epsilon so this is
basically you can see this is saying is
if you care about databases which are
much larger than the number of queries
you're asking then the best you can do
is the matrix mechanism I think where
I'll stop is what about smaller
databases is the last thing I'll say for
this session so let's look at say the
following very natural again class of
queries we have deep attribute binary
databases and we look at the queries
which ask our attributes I and J both
equal to 1 these are two-way marginals
and you can see what you can do a little
bit of computation it's not trivial it
takes a little bit of work but you can
show that the best that the match
mechanism achieves is roughly
proportional to the number of attributes
like this is how much worst case error
per query you can get okay and by what I
just showed on the slide if your
database is like big enough then this is
the best you can achieve up to log
factors however there are other
mechanisms that we'll talk about and you
know one of them is the prime
multiplicative waste mechanism that we
saw last learning yesterday
which achieve a different kind of error
bound so those are kind of incomparable
but you can see that if any small enough
this is better so it is not true that
the mechanism is good for all kind of
parameter regimes
it could be suboptimal it could be there
could be something better when any small
enough when you don't have that much
data I think this is something that will
come back in your own stock where he
will kind of show this source or more
empirically is the case okay so what is
really happening is that what we were
kind of showing is if you look at sort
of this optimal error for cup for some
set of counting queries as a function of
n this is always bounded because there
are things like like the Gaussian noise
mechanism in the mesh mechanism that add
noise it doesn't depend on the size of
the database and okay you like very I
mean this is a bit of a cartoon it's not
a real graph but you can think of it as
like some function that kind of grows
with n but it but it has like a bound
and what we could say is that the match
mechanism kind of matches this like
asymptote is like n goes to infinity but
in practice like froggy said theta is
expensive you want to do well also when
you have like not that much data and you
want to like match this curve more
closely and I think I'll stop here for
this session are the questions Oh
exactly now quick question before we
[ __ ] for lunch right yeah so I will be
if we can view this row and whatever the
other thing you hold my lambda tell
Vegas lease or to each one of them is by
Co is upper bounded by the spectral norm
bar this other thing is bounded by the
spectral norm of a can we like a metro
Pierce view makes this optimization
problem easier if you can for example
find the spectrum is less than the
spectrum yeah so it that sounds
interesting you it does make sense to
relax the optimization problem to make
it easier to solve I have now looked
much into this sort of being a being a
theorist maybe for too long have been
satisfied with like this is important on
your time and it's not I guess in
horrible Paulo no time cuz semi that
there they are like good semi definite
programming solvers but there is work
trying to give faster algorithms to
solve this problem and I think it's very
interesting and important and yeah some
some realization like this seems
reasonable yeah but I haven't seen
exactly what you're saying before
certainly the sort of matrices that come
up in application our special ranges
Census Bureau yes are enormous rare
enormous and they have you taken
literally and this is like explicitly
writing everything down yeah you
probably couldn't plug those into it so
Jerome will talk much more about that so
they're enormous they also have
structure and you can try to use the
structure to deal with the enormity
great good okay so let's think Sasha
this mini-course resumed at